ok let's start a new five-minute game I
want it is pretty high rated I don't
know him in the paradoxical something to
452 ok let's see we got a Spanish
opening or ruler pass it's going for the
exchange on variation I play a somewhat
rare sight line down there should be
seven so I'm not very well known but
it's not too bad III don't know that
move ok I think I play Knight f6 to
check your form
interestingly actually allows me to take
on on e4 maybe trying to utilize this
some somewhat better development but
from the structural point of view I
should be fine after capturing them
interesting now is some where to where
to go with the night all square some to
make sense somehow because I retreat you
have six but I also could have gone to
d6 on or C 50 k naan large no I should
be really really okay here i have to
Bishop paler as usual in the exchange
variation but I don't have a structural
problem with them white having 423 on
the King side because we exchange the
pawns
and I still have to the bishop pair for
for some long long-term plan here let's
show what he's up to
go play on push d six maybe
mmm 56 what what happens can play d4 f4
but he doesn't really want to play this
moves and then night c4 I need to check
out her page too huh at one hundred
percent sure but it looks dangerous
really tempted to try that okay he just
done he just covers son this was a piece
o to say okay my turn try and Queen to
f3 in the night f5 maybe yeah the Sun is
certainly a decent plan just finished
development night h5 is also an idea or
the only issue here is some if black
wants to wants to play for for a real
advantage it's no problem to have an
equal position here I can at the at the
very least I can always just chop this
night off only five and then with
opposite colored bishops and nothing
special happening against my king it's
um it's just a fine position but ok you
want to want to try a try a bit here
with the bishop pair haha
just so looks weird to me to close the
diagonal let's see if I can even try to
provoke see 3 yeah next next step would
be 97 too okay what is he doing
the wkds position really really a lot
here let's open it up okay on f5 I need
to retreat all the way back to see eight
but not sure this doesn't doesn't look
really good for white here the sole
configuration on the King side
he actually managed to make a very bad
piece out of this bishop okay imma take
on d4 now he might have rookie one I
guess that's the idea to make use of it
office a good development and that is a
decent plan really well so I think I
need to take what what else I came it
takes with rook I affirm Bishop c5 store
yeah my development is really a problem
I try to get the rook into play with
rook a 6 root g six maybe
please look T for now I have fruity six
now it's okay the bishop is not bad on
CH it's always attacking the f5 porn
okay let's chop this off to time morning
to give him the isolated pawn only issue
could be that a 5 4 sem is maybe we get
some point with the nazi for and stuff
like that okay it's understandable but
still on okay let's take this and now
cover cover of seven
don't think f6 is a problem I want to
undermine the night now really no one
time okay
wanted to play rookie to of course this
is not working okay it's got some silly
trick check check
play a six maybe
check
check check ah my mouse white forfeits
on time oh my god some i didn't i didn't
get a regrip all the mouth and he'll
used two seconds for for this okay we
both played exceptionally slow hmm yeah
I know I don't know somehow I lost
control of the position there but I
should have really really good position
around here he's got this dead bishop on
be too but of course he he got a real
attack going okay maybe c6 was was
stupid it's not necessary to play this
move was just a typical routine move to
to get the son pawned blocked all the
time maybe I should go for something
like a queen d 5 for instance 25 here it
looks like a good idea try to exchange
the queens and if he I don't know where
should he go there if he wants to avoid
the exchange he needs to go to ask where
most likely doesn't want to go to
Queenie to look stupid to Queen D 1 also
yeah I think this is just just much much
more precise okay now here don't
necessarily need to take their this
shouldn't be too bad okay now i have 7 s
an issue and always if 6 i'm not sure so
it's bad that i cannot play f6 because
of Queen f7 check king age 8 and 9 g 6
and the ages gone with me to follow
so I need to know to make some awkward
move to cover to cover f7 like this
never played but i still cannot play f6
because he ate the same ok this is maybe
at least are difficult from a practical
point of view yeah queen d 5 which was
much better much better and said RC six
yeah at the end of time decided he was
also very slow and my mouse cups made it
a very very close affair time-wise I'd I
wouldn't know tenth of a seconds left
okay